So welcome back. In the last video, we created some grass and flowers. This time we're going
to make a path which cuts through our PCG volumes. Now I'm back in the project here.
And just to confirm, we're in the content exercise one directory in the content browser.
And what you'll see is there is a blueprint called BP my underscore my path and I'll open this up
and you'll see this is a relatively simple blueprint. The main sections of it is we have a
spline which goes across the center here and that spline we're gonna we're gonna play around
with it a bit but that spline is going to be our path. But one of the things that is interesting
about it is we're going to class defaults and I'm going to search for tag. You'll see that this
has a path spline tag on the actor and that's important because we're going to use that in
order to identify the path within the PCG volume. Okay so now if I'm going to close this down,
jump back into the engine here. At the end what I'm going to do is I'm going to grab this path.
I'm going to drag it into normal and you'll see that we have a sort of we have a little
path element. Now I'm going to line this up as far as I can with the start here. This is where
I'd like to start it from. Now this has a spline as one of its components.
Now it's a little hard to see but if you come off of it here you can see that there is this
white line which comes out and it has an end point. What I want to do is I want to click
on that end point because that is going to allow me to move the point and sort of move
the path around like this. Now if you haven't played with splines before they can be a little
bit tricky but what we're creating is a line with different points and curves which this mesh
is going to follow. So I've just dragged one out but at the moment we haven't got any points
so it's just a single line. But if you hold down ALT and drag it out further you can see that
we get a bit more. Hold down ALT and I can drag it out further. Also right-hand click and
add a spline point if I want to change the way that it goes. But mainly what I'm going to do
is I'm going to drag this out. Make sure that it exists over the landscape all the way.
Pull it out like that. Like this. Again grabbing the end. Transform.
Now I'll come up to this point. Drag it over here and maybe it will finish at this end of the
section. Well okay so that might take a little bit of a while. If you're not used to working
with splines they are a little bit messy but it's just taking this mesh and it's just
just pushing it over the and it's just spreading it out over the environment.
And see that mesh? It even creates a second one which we might do later on
but that's enough for us at the moment. So we have a path. However this is not a very
pretty path at this point because it's floating above it. It's got a whole lot of other problems.
Now what we're going to do is we are going to use the virtual texture to actually
imprint it into our landscape. All you need to do is with the path selected,
with the top section selected here, we're going to grab the virtual texture.
Select the virtual texture that we've got. Now if you unselect it you'll see that the path
disappears but it is now part of the material of the landscape. Now
our path is a little bit difficult to see and that's because the path is covered in grass
and flowers. So that's what we are going to remove at this point. So I'm going to jump
back into my PCG graph and at this point all of the sampling from the world that we have
been doing has been as part of the landscape data. Now we're going to do a different sampling.
So for that we are going to get the spline data and then we are going to
sample the spline in a very similar way to what we previously did. So we'll pull off of a spline
sample. Now at the moment we need to make some changes because this is looking for a spline on
the self actor and that's not going to work in this manner because our actual actor doesn't have
a spline in it at all. It's an external actor from the PCG volume which has the spline.
So in our settings in the actor filter it's set to self. We're going to change that to
all world actors and we are going to identify them by tag. And this is why I bought up the
path spline was a default tag on that class. We're just going to add that in there.
I'm also going to hit the select multiple because we might put multiple paths in there
and we'll see how that looks. Okay so those are the three settings I'd like you to change on the
spline data that is all world actors by tag path spline as the tag. Now we have our spline
sampler and if I was to put a D on it though we're not going to see very much at all at this
point. So let's play around with the settings on the spline sampler.
Now the first thing is we're doing it the mode subdivision. Let's do it by distance. So that
is going to create a point mesh at every 100 centimeters. We're going to change that to 50.
And if there anything else we also want this to be unbounded as well in this case.
So now if I force regen you're going to see that we have a very very small
little points. Now we want to edit these points because this is too small. So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to drag off and again I'm going to go back to our trusty transform
heights turn D off on here and turn it on here. And for this transform points
what I really care about is the scale. So I'm going to tick on the absolute scale get rid of
uniform scale tick off the padlock of these points and I am going to set this one to 100
the Z to 200 and I'm going to do the same on these two points. Now bear in mind absolute
scale is important here. So if I was to now look into the world you would see that
we have a large point that goes all the way down our path. Okay so that's the kingdom piece.
So what we've effectively done is we've created a cutout so that we can use that to prevent
other things from generating. So let's work on that now. Now if you look we have
a couple of different difference nodes. We're going to start at the top. Now we're going to
want to remove rocks. So we'll need to add in a difference node here. So I'll disconnect
drag off and search for difference. Plug that in the output
again I want to set this difference to binary and the input in from the difference is going to
come all the way down from our path transform points. And we can do the same with the
difference in the trees and bushes and the difference in the grass. So if you were to
look at it there we've created our spine data at this point and we're using it to cut through
all three of our different point generation. So let's have a look. And now we have a path
that if I was to run you'd now see that it cuts through all of the different elements
go all the way down and we won't even have any rocks in the way or anything like that.
You could follow it all the way to the other end of the system. At that point I don't think
I think the spine was too high above the ground so it didn't intersect.
Same thing here we could fix these by increasing the height of let's do that now.
So on our transform points scale minimum 200 I'm going to make that 2000
both sides and now if I force regen see that's all gone now. So it's basically just made the
path cut out considerably taller. Okay so that is our path and that's just indicating
how we could use how we could use splines in order to to cut out or create things onto a
landscape.